hello welcome to another episode of not
too deep I'm your host grace Helbig
today is very exciting we have Gio and
Gina from just kidding news
just kidding studios hey [ __ ] the
podcast they are two lovely strong
fierce beautiful women and we had the
greatest time talking we also learned
that they might eventually at some point
star in a porn together and don't ever
[ __ ] with Gina because she will ruin
your life hear all about it on this
episode of not too deep today we have
support from Squarespace it's a joyous
day turn your great idea into a reality
with Squarespace they make it easier
than ever to launch your passion project
whether you're showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind they have
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything so you can
easily make a beautiful website all by
yourself but if you get stuck they have
24/7 award-winning customer support that
is there to help so go to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain thank you guys for being here
yeah this is so fun he's coming from
shooting stuff earlier today I am yeah
she was citing TV news yeah she was
shooting JK news I'm a degenerate that
wakes up at noon he's met up with her
over we all operate on different hours
of the day is the morning somewhere else
in the world trash every day find the
optimism here wait so you were just
saying you guys just shot 23 videos yeah
so on Jake your news days we shoot once
a week and we're always aiming for a
minimum of 28 videos a day that one day
that you shoot yeah yeah yeah so it's
like a full day of shooting so that's
why when you're breaking down you know
what we're gonna do today I'm like oh so
how did that even become the number
become like the the goal what you guys
made um before we used to do 40 40 on
this is you know
oh my god yeah on JK news YouTube we
were uploading I want to say like six
videos a day Wow yeah it was just a yeah
I don't like midnight geez basically you
film does it get edited immediately and
goes up immediately um so we have like
several editors and then that we just
get to distributed okay um but then we
started that once we had a stockpile so
it wasn't so rushed sure um but the ones
that do get you know turned out right
away are the ones that are like quick
hot topic yeah yeah like super big topic
so for people that don't understand what
the company is like how do you explain
it to people um so this particular
company is just kidding some sort of I
was just getting films we were doing
short form comedy and it was a lot of
satire stuff it's and then you know
YouTube's change and then people were
like okay well I don't give a [ __ ] about
skits yeah and then it was more like I
want to know what you do in your life
yeah yeah so then from that point we're
like what are we doing man like it takes
us so many days to write a script and
then to produce the the script and then
to like cat and do all that [ __ ] that we
were just like okay forget it yeah so
then what we were doing was we would you
know once we would call cut it then we
just sit here in a circle and we're just
talking about life and giving our
opinions on things and current events
what's going on yeah yeah and one of the
founders cuz it's Bart and Joe like we
we're just cast on it or whatever but um
Bart was like my husband Jordan if you
happen to watch this
we love women supporting women but we
also know yeah so we were just talking
around in a circle like this he's like
hey when I was just make this into
YouTube yeah and then seven years later
I'm here we're still doing it so it's
like a ghetto version of the view I
explain to people it's like a like
imagine like a TMZ setting sort of like
in a room world of sitting together
talking but instead of celebrities well
sometimes slippery's but we're talking
more about like current events and we're
all dumb about it basically yeah yeah
but it's a real it's a genuine
conversation yeah it is that's I think
what's so appealing about it it makes it
so easy to watch is that you're watching
people discover things and also discover
like their own opinions about yeah it's
yeah we judge each other yeah but it's a
lot of like friendly I want out of my
podcast and I want in on yours but you
okay so how do you go about the stories
that you talk about how does that
doesn't is it someone's responsibility
every episode to present a story that
you all are blind to yeah exactly
basically well we have like viewers send
in articles that they wanted to talk
about to our website and then we have
someone that kind of accumulates all the
interesting articles and then usually
it's her with a laptop it's our friend
Tiffany uh-huh she has her laptop and
then our guest is the one that gets to
read out like oh no in something
something news this happened in eurasia
or whatever you know okay and then
that's when we all start discussing it
together yeah but no one knows this
story we dope cuz that's my ideal
situation oh yeah I don't have to work I
just show up you get to have a genuine
reaction to something yeah it's so easy
to do yeah it's really cool the UM have
you I mean you've been doing this now
for seven years you said well the whole
YouTube grind has been like 12 years oh
dang yeah that's so not so in that time
have you realized like when where the
line is and not across
dude we can't even cuss anymore yeah
oh yeah I saw because you guys now have
moved over to patreon because there's
more stability and you'll get to
actually create a community with your
you know engaged fans that support you
but yes because on YouTube they're like
D monetizing news stories and I think
everything like if the title is wrong or
the thumbnail is wrong or what else
happens in all caps lock it strangely
yeah and they never tell where they go
they never tell you what the guidelines
are so it's just a game of guessing all
the time like everyone we're gonna get
to monetize yeah that's so frustrated I
hate it I [ __ ] hate it but that's so
nothing that's so like discouraging yeah
it is cuz then you're like what can we
talk about exactly it kind of uh I guess
like stunts our personalities too
because our channel like our videos
would be like oh man gets killed by
roller coaster but we have to change the
title - man gets
ended by roller coaster - yeah life ends
but it's it's kind of it doesn't suit us
very well yeah it's not now you would
normally describe it to a group of
friends if you were just hanging out
without cameras exactly yeah that's so
interesting but then now you guys have I
mean you guys do it so much both of you
individually and collectively so you
have the news you have podcasting right
mm-hmm
and it's an all-female podcast that you
guys just started hey [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah thanks for no no that's so cool
I mean this feels like a natural
progression from the news to be like all
the ladies seem to get along here we go
talk yeah it was fun we uh we had a apus
ode of we had a film and JK news with
just all girls it's really let's see
what happens yeah it turned out to be
incredible and our viewers loved it yeah
and then Gio Satta story kind of like
hit us all up because we have a group
chat obviously called with the cult it's
called a host base it's a safe space for
hos
really very comforting about like it's
your safe space yeah we have like a
vetting process we have people that come
in we're like hey so we heard about this
yeah we really yeah we could awkward for
us okay please don't ask us to be you
know because that's too much ability my
mom just texted me that I haven't called
her so like I have other obligations
responsibilities
I appreciate the obvious offer that was
about to happen so this is the group
chat with all the girls from the podcast
right originally there was what like
five of us yes yes and then so we were
talking and talking just like it was
everything from like I'm depressed today
to look at this dick the conversation
yeah because I'm like okay like this is
the conversation that you have with the
best friend but then to have five others
now at six are the girls with the same
mindset mm-hmm and it's like hey me and
my husband like we're going through some
really rough times like we're not even
having sex anymore this nut and we're
all going in there going like girl and
then someone else comes in like yo this
guy just sent me this big picture it's
almost like it may be this is not the
correct analogy but it's like a group of
how everyone watches queer eye and they
wish that they had that support no
people it seems like that almost where
it really is here's my mess today I need
your support
ya know we went from like all that
craziness and then one day Jill put us
all like we a couple of other people
didn't want to be maybe like not they
wouldn't fit very well I suppose a
little bit more um yeah they had class
and morals yeah they had boundary and so
Gio put like the shitty ones
she was in a group and she was like hey
hear me out this might sound crazy but
what do you guys think of starting a
podcast and we were just all on it like
yes yeah absolutely
that you had dude like it was like the
[ __ ] ground movie so Geo
she's like the she's um she's kind of
like the the Builder mm-hmm logistics
and everything she she knows everything
that needs to be done like this is how
because she had it she has her podcast
with her husband right that cast right
so she already knew how to do all these
things I don't come from that at all I
don't think any of us had podcasts at
that point until you guys her before you
guys right so she put us all together
she's like this chat is [ __ ] wild
like I feel like people would love to
hear this and it's just like a group of
sisters and we should be other people's
big sisters yeah and so that's how she
brought it up and we were just on board
immediately and then everyone was like I
want to do this I wanna do this I won't
do that and that was the birth of the
hey [ __ ] podcast that's so cool and how
the conversation seems super candid is
that do you guys go in with a general
topic idea and then just like let
conversation flow is that how it works
yeah so we uh like we came up with a
bunch of topics right and then we kind
of narrowed it down to what does anyone
everyone wanna talk about and then it's
like okay everybody shut up don't like
save it for camera yeah yeah that's when
it becomes hard you can't be friends
anymore we do and literally it's like
cage gladiators when we hang out then
it's like hello how are you good how are
you can we turn the microphones on it'll
actually start talking to you yeah yeah
like how do you you guys is the group
chat still as spicy with the podcast
non-existing yeah so yeah it still
happens but like now it's hardcore
damn I love I can totally get off my
meds now yeah try it yeah have you guys
talked about you said a little bit
before like have you said anything on
there that you're like oh god I gotta
watch myself now like I might have over
shared or surprising overshare to the
point that like the response you got was
like thank you so much for opening up so
this question is assuming we're
embarrassed of yeah you guys have that
muscle or emotional like that I don't
think that of us I think you should be
embarrassed about a couple minutes I
should or have you been surprised has
there been a topic or a conversation
that has been the most surprising in
terms of response that you've gotten
okay so we like it since it's such a
wild podcast and goes from like can you
take it up the ass too we we get like
holy [ __ ] that like we get comments and
messages like that's wild but my
favorite ones are personally the ones
are like they're more like um like
younger 20s teen girls or 20s girls and
they're like hey like I never knew this
about like my health my vaginal health
my mental health thank you for teaching
me this you guys are like the big
sisters who never had whenever I get
that I want to start crying because
that's like personally for me I think
for a lot of us that was like our big
thing we want to teach people because a
lot of us didn't have yeah I didn't say
please or a sister yeah so it we felt
like we want to fulfill that part yeah
who did you talk to growing up myself in
my head yeah I had an older brother that
I used to like pray would become an
older sister when I woke up in the
morning I just wanted someone that like
guided me yeah and I mean you know we're
probably all the same age group that
like I didn't have the internet when I
was younger like when I was in middle
school or anything or it was just
starting at that time so finding anyone
out there that was having any sort of
conversations was like next to
impossible yeah that's why I was like
desperate to read Seventeen magazine
because there was like the closest I got
to like a female influence yeah yeah but
that's so far anything for us like I
like my mom would never even talk to me
about like a period yeah and then the
time that like
had the conversation about like your
body's going to change we were literally
back to back and my mom was like cooking
and then she goes just to let you know
you're gonna get hair in weird places
but you better not tell anybody because
I don't want parents coming to me and
complaining that my daughter it was so
it was so awkward man like I had zero
guidance that's so nuts but it's so
great to recognize that and then be able
to create this like group of people that
probably I'm assuming the rest of the
group also has similar kind of
connections in like ways that they were
raised yes but also now you're a mom
yeah so being a mom now what's that
responsibility like does that shift your
perspective on the way your mom mom do
you I'm grateful for the way my mom
raised me did you've done that's - yeah
I mean I have Instagram your son has a
very large Instagram followers a very
large head they say that people with big
heads make great like entertainers
that's why oh yeah the guy that started
yes yeah the guy who created wheel of
fortune sought out Pat Sajak and Vanna
White specifically because they look
like bobblehead dolls because it's
whatever reason on TV makes them seem
more likable Oh caricatures yeah exactly
like a caricature I don't know if that's
true I heard it one time from one person
and now I yeah I think we're just gonna
like that we're gonna like stay here now
okay can renaming this podcast
therapy but no so you now you're into
your mom now yep how does that affect
how you handle social media if at all um
nothing really changed no if anything it
was just like oh cool I have like this
this like new little like buddy
but yeah I don't know I don't think
anything really changed other than like
I'm challenged a lot more now mm-hmm
and I'm like having to decipher with
this like little child is trying to tell
me and like yet does he have a person
like can you start to see his
personality yeah I hate it he's kind of
smart like really smart so like
dangerous yeah dude like he gets bored
really easily and he just doesn't like
you'll understand the direction that
your whatever your tell me I'm gonna do
but he's more like I'm gonna do whatever
I want and I'm like holy [ __ ] what did I
just do fearless oh no he's actively
trying to kill himself Alyssa forgot his
mom yeah yeah he said oh there you
that's a great description on a daily
he's trying to kill himself Wow yeah
that's good I just needed a reminder why
I don't have one of those things right
under birth control
truly I when I see everyone else I mean
his Instagram makes him look very sweet
yeah you like I know I did that on
purpose
caption evil like you that's funny she
was saying the car she's like grace is
gonna be like who the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
I cannot pronounce her arse no the
captions for her dog in the voice of
what she believes that yeah I guess so I
get it no grace right now okay we gotta
stop this positivity [ __ ] real with me
but it makes me laugh because when I see
people do that I imagine you with your
phone oh yeah typing it out and then
getting the autocorrect is this what you
meant and then hitting X and retyping it
out misspelled literally what
and as I'm writing it I'm like this is
so [ __ ] stupid like I just have to do
it but yeah me and my husband we do
write it I love it so if I tricked
anyone out there that thought my son was
actually writing it my dad all part of
the brand yeah um so what how did you
guys meet each other we met a way but
Jesus Christ way back when I'm tinder on
tinder huh just swipe away Jackie films
jakie films yes so this is back when
before I even touched YouTube at all I
met someone who was in YouTube and he
was like hey you know our lead star
dropped off on this little series that
we were doing oh my god you burped plan
B plan a so they brought me in and then
Bart and Joe from JK were brought in as
guest stars a cameos right mm-hmm I've
seen these guys in high school and oh
you went to the same high school
oh no we did go to the same high school
but they were a few years older than me
but you didn't go to this end yeah but
we never cross paths yeah so after we
filmed that I get a phone call I think
I'm pretty sure it was from you okay um
she was their producer at the time okay
like there was like a small so you
weren't on camera she was I was off you
know YouTube back in the day yeah
everything yeah
yeah got it and she hit me up she's like
hey Gina you don't know me I'm Gio
Barton jo met you a couple weeks ago
listen so we're looking for someone
who's Asian pretty and with big boobs
for a video right so then I got brought
in a member what our first kid was I
don't know but you were probably just
like Hoey yeah in the group right and
and
and they're in our chemistry worked out
really well so they kept on asked me to
come back many ventures like hey do you
want to get on to JK news yeah so I just
started filming with them a lot more
than we got closer and closer over the
years yeah most of our relationships
just happened pretty organically like
Weaver gel and we like pull you into our
family or we don't and we're just like
cool yeah cuz how does it is there like
a set cast is that how it worked or is
it kind of like a revolving door of
people come in and out when they can
it's a pretty set cast okay yeah it's a
pretty set cast and then we'll like have
a guest or whatever but then once you
know we really gel it cuz we're just so
weird specific energy to the group like
so I'm sure you can tell when people
don't mesh well yeah pretty obvious
we're just like man we're gonna make
these people really bad yeah I feel like
it's different for us because we have
our group right and when we bring in
people that we really like yeah they
always come back but we don't really
venture out you know
oh yeah we're pretty introverted yeah
yeah always ask me do you know who this
youtuber is and it's like some young
like super Disney Channel as no no I'm
so out of the mix understanding I mean I
went to VidCon for like 12 hours this
year and that was it 12 hours did you do
that all my stuff done all in one day
and pieced out I was just I didn't even
walking around I was just like I feel
like a fraud here yeah I truly don't
know if that little like 13 oh boy is
like a tick-tock thing I don't
understand it that was that playlist I
felt like yeah why am I here right now I
felt so old yeah do you feel any sense
of like pressure to stay like connected
in the YouTube community at all or have
you guys kind of always done your own
thing and that's what works better if
it's that you've never heard of us
oh no I've seen you guys for years oh
it's just like five years ago when yeah
like when SourceFed started and with
like all these news like kind of
situations going on or at least there
was more discoverability I guess of them
because that was like a more popular
thing yeah yeah I thought it was so cool
I was like I want a group of friends
like that
like they're having fun just talking
yeah cool yeah but for the most part we
just kind of stay with ourselves yes cuz
we're like in Tripoli and we're like we
don't talk to people there we are we're
weird we're like old school YouTube and
it's just so new now like I remember
someone telling me like oh you should
consider going PG and go like super hey
guys welcome to my channel and I'm like
I will kill myself yeah you know thank
you know it's it's it's hard to embrace
that YouTube now you know yeah I like
what we have
ya know you guys have a classic thing it
feels like you're staying very true to
yourselves which i think is hard for
people because everyone's try and if I
hear the word algorithm like in another
time and I don't I've never paid a penny
I don't know what it is I don't know how
to follow it yeah it's probably changing
as I talk like I don't know yeah but
that's very cool okay we're gonna take a
quick break and then when I get back I
have a bunch more questions for you guys
then we have a ton of Twitter questions
oh no it's not really good and like
these are probably some of the best
Twitter questions we've gotten in a long
time we got a Squarespace sponsor today
that's right turn your dream into a
reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project if you're looking to start a new
business showcase your work published
content some products or more and
they're the tool for you they have
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks so you can easily make a
beautiful website all by yourself they
also have a powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and analytics that help
you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
on the box and there's nothing to patch
or upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and you'll get the help you need with
their 24/7 award-winning customer
support they empower millions of people
designers lawyers artists gamers
restaurants gyms to turn great ideas
into something real so go to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace save 10% on
your first purchase of a website we're
done
that squarespace.com slash grace offer
code grace support for today's show
comes from bareMinerals the creators of
clean beauty purity in formulation and
uncompromising performance have always
been the guiding principles of bare
minerals because they believe that
makeup and skin care should make your
skin better not just better looking
that's been their philosophy since they
began the clean beauty revolution in
1995 with their best-selling original
foundation that offers creamy
lightweight buildable coverage that's
naturally luminous and their clean
formula is made with only 5 good for
skin ingredients all minerals including
non-chemical SPF protection makeup so
pure you can sleep in it and it actually
improves your skin over time it's
everything your skin needs and nothing
that it doesn't for bareMinerals to be
clean without compromise means good for
skin formulas with proven performance
like every bare minerals product it's
100% cruelty free and better yet the
original and matte loose powder
foundations are available in 30 shades
so upgrade to clean beauty products use
the foundation finder at bare minerals
dot-com to find your perfect match first
time customers will get 15% off when use
the promo code not too deep that's bare
minerals calm promo code not too deep
for 15% off your first purchase bare
minerals the power of good we're all and
we're back um do you guys have any
blackmail on each other
blackmail oh [ __ ] yeah the random nipple
video the other day that's good to have
that like balance of a friendship that
way exactly
you just have a 30th birthday party
Jesus Christ you really dug yeah yeah
well I mean I don't dig that far yes
photos but wasn't there like some sort
of misshapen man and you don't have to
tell I just feel bad for anyone that
ever like does Tina dirty because she
goes in Soho no we're even talking about
it on a different podcast I just feel
bad for the person okay and now I cannot
wait for this context right so I hired a
caterer yeah and he was recommended well
he what's his name his name is Chris
there we go hired him and long story
short he breached his contract he left
halfway through the party well and took
his whole staff with him left a mess for
any specific reason or he's like I'm
tired I'm done
give her the excuse so the first excuse
was well the neighbors came over and
told my staff that if we don't leave the
cops will come I'm like okay that was
sense you should be in like a rented
place yeah yeah house a big house to
like just you know have everyone there
and and then the next one was well
someone junk shoved my brothers so we
felt like we needed to leave so there
were two excuse two very different
excuses and then my brother got in a car
accident so I had to leave and go to the
hospital yeah I'm like bro this all
happened in like ten minutes
did your brother get in the accident
before after you got and then so and
then and then it was it that and he told
me that after ignoring my text messages
my calls for like a full 24 hours Oh God
although he responded to my party
planner which is really strange uh-huh
so my party planner told him like you
need to respond to Gina because it's
gonna get ugly yeah and then so he
finally responded gave me that excuse
I'm like you have like I want a partial
refund because it did part of your job
you know but you stayed half the time
yeah
Yeah right so um that drag not it's
still drag not it's still unresolved my
birthday was July it was the party's
July 27th it's now September 5th and
then I got another excuse a couple weeks
later a picture of a prescription pad
and his grandfather in a wheelchair in a
hospital my grandfather just had surgery
so I had to pay for his body blood a
white dude in response to you'd wanting
a refund yeah so I was like that's when
I got really fed up like I gave him more
than enough time very nice yeah you know
a month at this point I was like you
know what dude if you're not gonna
handle this I'll take care of this way I
know how to take care of it uh-huh so so
we filmed an episode of just kidding
news and we have a segment called
off-the-record where we just talk about
whatever yeah how's your weekend what's
going on and then they were like Jeana
so I was explaining the story to them
and I was so pissed and I do this when
I'm pissed
I just really petty I get really petty
that's yeah because gets [ __ ] done it
really does so I drop his Instagram
handle uh-huh and within 10 minutes of
that episode going live our fans are the
best
yeah what happened so they blew up his
Instagram page in the back you broke
[ __ ] lately like they're collecting for
me
Wow and suddenly somebody learned how to
text oh man these bones started working
again it was magic weird yeah like Gina
please take down the video I'll pay you
back I promise I'm taking out loans like
you needed a loan for this was like 500
bucks by the way Wow a loan for that and
then just like you're you're ruining my
business like I told y'all pay and like
we didn't [ __ ] pay yeah you're
ruining your business yeah exactly and
then oh and then he sends me a picture
of his dog with blood all over it
we know this part okay so yeah there was
an update he was like my dog just got
attacked so I had to pay for the vet
bills I'm like are you actively killing
your family it's gone why is everyone
died animal that's connected to you
getting hurt and so the constant what is
going on and also why is he sending you
all of these very specifically weird I
like and then I messaged him I was like
one I don't want excuses I want money
and - I don't give a [ __ ] what's going
on with your families his business ya
know and then um and then I wake up so
he ends up deleting his Instagram oh my
god and then people got to his email so
he was inside I wake up the next day - a
simple text that says you destroyed me I
just went to go eat with my family in
Monterey Park this is a very Asian dense
city and it's a big part of where our
fan bases yeah it's like someone came up
to me and said are you Chris you should
be ashamed of yourself for not paying
Gina back I like I was embarrassed in
public and I'm like [ __ ] I smells like
a personal problem wait and at this
point had he paid you back so he was
like he said he been bugging me 125
bucks
126 bucks very random which I'm assuming
is that's because that's all he had left
he's in the negatives he's like this is
for good faith that I'll pay you and
then he said I'll pay you everything
September faith well today is September
5th yeah guess what a [ __ ] did this
morning the first day she woke up I went
on Twitter it's September 5th
PTSD I'm sure dude because right now
it's not even a matter of the money hey
principal yeah you know and so he sent
me a hundred bucks and so this was like
literally like 15 mins before we got
here he sent me a hundred bucks and he's
like I'm gonna make payments every week
until I'm done paying you off I'm so
sorry for doing this man whatever oh my
god how did this man run a business how
this has been survived yeah how did you
find him yeah so he reached out to me
saying hey I did your friends event it
was our buddy Tim delegate oh okay Tim I
was like hey is he cool yeah he's fine
and then so Tim's like a foodie person
too right it was also really really nice
kid could like shut in Tim's mouth and
would've been fine so that like we're
still resolving suddenly I wanted to
kind of take it to small claims but I
don't really you think isn't worth your
time yeah oh yeah she's gone viral so
many times and teaching people not to
[ __ ] other people over clear rules in
business like do your job and you'll get
paid yeah I do it for myself I do it for
my friends for my loved ones like [ __ ]
happens and you get [ __ ] done that's
amazing that's insane yeah what is your
fan base like in terms of what
specifically like are they like
teenagers are they like usually
something like 18 to like 34 okay so
it's an older crowd and it's like high
schoolers no no not really
hmm and like their it initially it just
started off as a bunch of Asians yes
that's what we were catering to and then
out of nowhere we'll have like like 50
year old Hispanic men you know I love
your show really thank you there is this
man that came up to me like I was in the
Midwest cutoff t-shirt uh-huh like just
holding a beer hey are you from JK news
I was like no [ __ ] belly he's like I
just wanna let y'all know y'all funny as
hell recognize this we're like holy [ __ ]
we broke through somehow
and for some reason so much more
rewarding is lately confusing yeah like
we are doing something right I don't
know what it is breaking out no I
remember I was in Atlanta mm-hmm two
black people you must also get a lot of
hate
well hate obviously we all do yeah but
our support from like being a diverse
group on the internet that like young
people probably are like I don't get to
see myself on like certain things it's
really nice to see like this group of
like cuz it's mostly you guys are mostly
all like Asians Yeah right well I'm
Mexican but I can yeah yeah so that must
be really nicest that have kids that
probably feel that way about it yeah
absolutely like we'll get stuff like hey
I was going through you know I'm going
through the same situation of my parents
being really strict you know in their
Mexican and I have this curfew but I'm
like 32 yeah well yeah I can relate yeah
Podcast like everyone kind of finds
themselves in each cast member like we
have like we have a rainbow of people
and then like with different lifestyles
you know like we had a team we have a
team mom yep yes Cantina and then like
just all different source people no
white girl from the south white girl
from the south yeah we have a black girl
we have Vietnamese we have a hapa okay
yeah yeah but that's amazing because
that's so many more different
perspectives
yeah it's such an interesting and then
to talk about topics that affect
everyone but affect everyone differently
I know you get a wider range
things you know can relate to the well
thing is um we we're doing it because
it's just genuinely fun for us and yeah
and we're just like cool we get to see
each other you just go oh wait don't you
guys go on that girl trips together -
yeah something I never knew existed
until I started watching Real Housewives
and like every season they all go on
like a girl trip and I'm like that yeah
we exist in real life but you guys are
doing it yeah cuz this is new for me -
yeah it definitely is new for me because
I I really do keep to myself I have like
a couple friends from high school that I
sang out with like girl trip right or
girl trips this is the first group where
I'm like Hulk rattling we have a girl
group like if I want to do a shitty
bachelor bachelorette party like we're
all going yeah yeah yeah where did you
guys go
Tulum Tulum how was that I couldn't go
oh yeah it might hurt you were there
thank you yeah man it was nice cuz um we
like we hang out as a big group so it
was good to just kind of vent about
husbands or significant others and just
like go topless and I mean where there's
no one else or ho yeah and this is [ __ ]
we would never do like mm-hmm
anywhere else cuz we're either with our
significant other or we just don't have
that support group where we're like that
free yeah it was really nice to just be
completely free and not give two shits
about being judged or that's awesome
someone saying something in front of
your face and then something behind your
backs
yeah and you you work with your husband
yeah so what's that like it's nice yeah
we've been working together I think
those 12 year the the 12 years like we
did the JK Films thing which is him in
our my friend Joe's business and then we
opened up our own channel
Barton geo and then we started a gym
yeah you guys also have a gym like that
yeah like when I go through the notes on
like the research for you guys I'm like
there do you think so [ __ ] much
younger it's stupid what started the
idea they even started I don't even do
it's a gym we didn't know either yeah we
had no idea so we've just always kind of
been intimate into fitness so he's
done like the you know the the
bodybuilding thing okay and I played
sports in college so we've always kind
of just been active people mm-hmm and
then we got into cross finish type thing
when it was first starting gotcha
so when we would train at our regular
gym people are looking at us like what
the hell are these people doing like
there's we rowing chairs around
I got super into a crossword documentary
on a plane a couple months ago and it
was like I'll never do it but I get that
this is super fun for these people and
then I was like texting my boyfriend
making jokes about the documentary of
being there and then they're gonna do
like handstands and walk through a swamp
and then they did that it's like this is
insanity
you know this you know like my kids
trying to kill himself on a daily up
that way yeah so we were doing that and
then we got kicked out of the gym so
we're like with you got kicked out for
doing good all the chairs I didn't know
this this is hilarious
what cuz we were slamming things not on
purpose nothing like yeah it's all it's
got an intention right yeah yeah so then
we're like okay well we got to find a
gym and then in looking for gyms were
like men all these are kind of whack mmm
so then my husband was like okay well
what if I put our gym in our living room
and we like lived in like an 800-foot a
square foot place uh-huh
which is like tiny oh yeah what the hell
are you thinking like hell no we're not
gonna do that um so then he's like okay
I'll get a container and we'll work out
of a container no those truck like
storage container okay um and then a
bunch of people were like okay if you
start that all I'll sign up like yeah
well Wow Jen for that and we're like oh
[ __ ] I think we're on to something
started yeah basically Wow and how long
have you been doing that since uh 2013
oh wow yeah it's been a little bit
that's not I know have you is it it's
not specifically a CrossFit no it's an
open gym but it's all free weights so if
you're looking for like cardio machines
and like heavier on the machine inside
yeah I wouldn't recommend us but if you
want more of like hardcore
like not hardcore in the way it's
growling at each other terrifying
at once I don't want to cry no it's not
your
back me up is awful
you're fired from the marketing it's
because it's terrifying because there's
a lot of results in there in there once
just cuz I was you would like brave like
a day feeling confident yeah yeah and I
walked in these fools thighs are bigger
than my whole existence and like I went
and I benched the bar yeah that's
probably my limit yeah and like these
people are like throwing chairs
it's an incredible gym like they'll
train you the music's always like super
high yeah there we go that was the big
takeaway from this crossword documentary
is that they were all having the best
time ever
yeah it was almost like cult ish I mean
a little bit they're doing it like the
world's top level so they're all you're
drinking their own kool-aid but I was
like I get there they must just be
running on endorphins 24 hours a day
it's pretty nuts it's three minutes
we're not there but so how do you even
like fine train like you hire trainer so
well that's just an open gym like
literally we wanted to keep it very
basic because we're very basic people
and it was just literally us doing it
for ourselves like it was a very selfish
reason because we're like we didn't
can't find what we want we're gonna
create what we want if you want to come
that's on you
yeah yeah yeah even like the memberships
really easy like there's no contracts
it's like it's just month to month and
it's like pretty straightforward we
don't have like personal trainers that
like are constantly trying to sell you
should more like if you want help our
staff can help you because everyone
lives yeah and it's just really chill
that's a cool take a literal open door
exactly that's awesome because of that
we get a bunch of crazy people I'm gonna
say the other end of it like the coin
yeah people that comment have you ever
had to like remove some yeah we've had
yeah we've had people like touch people
and appropriately
we're like what are you doing dude yeah
in a gym full of huge people that can be
like everyone can jump on you yeah we've
had a bunch of characters for sure
they're just people will pay like
because it's a hundred other membership
so they'll pay the membership just to
sit there and launch people like you
can't do that either bro yeah yeah oh
that's sketchy yeah yeah there must be
so many unforeseen like things to deal
with because I can't even imagine like
what you need to do to even start
something like that yeah I mean but
everyone lifts so they're pretty strong
so it's okay to kill people though yeah
you should come and be on a barbell
Brigade video I think that would be wait
what are these oh nice well barbell
brigade is the name of the game yeah
okay yeah and then they just put you
through a workout and then god I would
suffer see you follow yeah so terribly
at all I was like trying to fix my couch
the other day and I could not do it this
is now a problem like what do you bug
lips happens I'm just gonna you know
take myself out I'm not trying I don't I
might be an optimistic person but when
that like happens I'm like I don't see
the reason I don't I'm not I'm hanging
out with you two [ __ ] I'm just
throwing yes absolutely we know our
roles but so you work so directly with
your husband yeah so much stuff do you
guys have like an unspoken rule of like
I need space or like I can't be around
you or no you just saw each other so
civilized but not um no I don't know
like I mean like everything does
spillover like when we're doing business
stuff then I'm probably still holding on
to an argument we just had sharp
so he's like showing me a design on like
when I guess it's okay spills over so
much or vice versa like I'm trying to be
intimate with him and and like I'm you
know I'm trying to put the moves on um
in chat and like warm him up and he's
like you know actually I was thinking
that maybe we can do I'm like shut the
whole hour now
turn it off yeah it's hard it's really
hard that's interesting but it must also
be really fun it's super fun and I
really enjoy it cuz he's just a very
fair guy and we both try to be very fair
and encouraging so like we see the best
in each other when I guess we don't see
it in ourselves so he's very encouraging
like no you should do that try that or
like good job and I'm like these goddamn
brushes together I'm sure I mean you
hardly need to be working and on so many
different projects for so long you have
to have a pretty good working
relationship I just think it's him that
has a really really good patience he's a
really Zen I feel sweet it's more him
than me he truly is
yeah no where's your dating situation
ouch
oh my god she went there she did ask us
what's the one thing she's not supposed
to bring up it's really it's really I'm
very vague about my dating life oh yeah
for years and years and years everyone's
like who you dating who you dating me
dating and I'm very um I'm very careful
with who I post publicly yeah so I all
the stories I tell never makes sense
timeline wise because I always jumble
them up gotcha all right yeah so people
always like is she like any like if
there's like a man's elbow in a photo
they're like she's dating yeah you know
and four years on YouTube if I do a
video with somebody like our friend
David like oh they're dating yeah years
a thousand David and I were dating you
know so it's I like I kind of like
having fun into mystery yeah it's fun
and also you do a lot of streaming right
like you play a game like what's your
go-to currently right now I well I play
a lot of shooters so I am playing apex
legends okay this is a foreign language
to me - that's me with her Jim okay
shaded in that world and that I mean
that's a has been a very male-dominated
world do you find that like the people
that keep Munich a door with you on
there is it like a much different
scenario than just kidding absolutely
the audience there yeah
you if you ever have a chance anyone
just go on her livestream cuz if someone
gives her like any [ __ ] you're like oh
you're so ugly she'll pull up she'll
pull up with her picture and she like
blows it up next and it's like 30
minutes of straight roasting do not
cross cybersecurity yeah yeah it is I
came into this knowing it's a very
male-dominated industry mm-hmm but it's
something that I've loved for so long
played games since I was a kid yeah and
I'm not gonna lie like it works both
ways for me I know how to work it both
ways like yeah men are gonna treat me a
certain way but also I can get a lot of
things just being a very few females and
I will use that yeah to my advantage
it's smart lady affect your dating world
at all does no no actually that's a good
question okay yes it does I I dated
someone briefly a little while back Oh
God drunk one night and FaceTime me and
said he's never told me this and then he
was like I gotta tell you something I'm
like why he goes I am so scared of you
[Applause]
he's like I've been scared since like
day one what do you mean cuz I'm so
scared of messing this up I've never
been with someone so powerful about yeah
right like but it was also a red flag
yeah I mean yeah oh you're scared of me
yeah because he was a very like super
wholesome family well it's a very beta
major very alpha he was yeah he's not
used to another alpha okay he was up
until like two years before like a
former fat boy got shot became super
buff handsome made money uh-huh from a
wholesome family the parents are still
together okay
and yeah that's a big thing right weird
yeah and then he and here he is with me
like he's he's like personality a 95 9
personality be creative right yeah and
like he's like I've never dated anyone
like you um where if I if someone [ __ ]
with you you go and ruin life he's like
I've never had anyone that can take care
of herself and then he got it in his
head for some reason this was like the
funniest thing so we ended up calling it
off like within a month or so because he
was so scared he sat me down and then he
was like Gina I need to tell you
something I'm like ok and it was like he
was just like really trying to get it
out he goes I fly coach where do you
meet the people that you meet some sort
of like code yeah he goes no because
like the last time you flew you said
that you flew first class and he assumed
that I foaming sauce everywhere
lifestyle and then he was like I don't I
like you have like all these nice things
and I'm like bro like you know I just
like horf down some chicken nugget
things threw up right yeah hey you'd
like this crazy picture of me of like so
you were like alpha monster right yeah
and then that's when I realized like
this is where your insecurities came out
like you liyan never yeah yeah we handle
this you like you thought it was fun for
a little bit then you realize that you
were scared yeah it does affect my
dating life yeah and my schedule like
with streaming and stuff my schedules
like completely nocturnal so there goes
all like the quality time is them so it
does affect my dating life but that's
the point where I'm like I'll change it
like yeah exactly yeah so it's it's it's
fun like it I'm having fun I'm not gonna
change it for someone that I just that
makes total sense yeah and we learned
that you only fly first class damn
she's bougie okay we're gonna take one
last break when we get back we have a
ton of Twitter questions for you guys
[Music]
today we have some sponsorship from hi
MIT they're putting hanging into your
hands I'm talking about domestic design
hanging things in your house can be
overwhelming the second you have to get
out of a tool it's a brand new project
and it just gets messy so your favorite
art gets left on the ground and floating
shelves are bought but never put up you
know that I know this world I lead with
the best intentions of wanting to have
my house look beautiful but my execution
is incredibly terrible but now lose the
anxiety with high MIT you can hang
without needing a single tool you just
place push hang and it's up they offer
strong and easy to install hanging
products that include wall hangers
decorative hooks and floating shelves
their hangers hold up to 125 pounds so
there's no such thing as something too
heavy to hang floating shelves come with
their own level and install in minutes
this makes everything so simple it's
fantastic find out where you can get
your full products online and watch
how-to videos at design to be stuck up
comm slash grace again find out where
you can get the full line of their
products and watch how-to videos at
design to be stuck up calm slash grace
designed to be stuck up calm slash grace
if there's something that's interfering
with your happiness or preventing you
from achieving your goals better help
online counseling can help they offer
licensed professional counselors who are
specialized in issues like depression
anxiety relationships trauma anger
family conflicts LGBTQ matters grief
self esteem and more connect with your
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment get the help
that you need at your own time at your
own pace anything you share is
confidential and it's convenient you can
schedule secure video or phone sessions
as well as chat and text with your
therapist and if for some reason you're
not happy with your counselor you can
request a new one at any time for no
additional charge
best of all it's affordable and you'll
get 10% off your first month with a
discount code grace so why not get
started today go to better help calm
slash grace fill out a questionnaire
that helps them assess your needs and
match you with a counselor that you will
love again better help calm such grace
okay before we get into these Twitter
questions I'm gonna ask you the two
questions ask every single guest that's
on the podcast and the first is who
alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at Oh cold
spaghetti do I get a pic where I throw
it sure alive or dead oh man Jeana you
go first
alive or dead right now it's like dude
like do they like the spaghetti is your
intention yeah however you would like to
throw it Howie Mandel and I know he's
kind of a germaphobe super German yeah
so I just want to see the reaction with
like just a bowl spaghetti at his head
yeah also like to see that happen I'm
gonna panic I don't know I'm just gonna
say Santa Claus yeah I can see that
thank you I mean I feel like I don't
know with and does Santa eat spaghetti
you look at him right well true Ramsey
you'll probably yell at you for the
screaming I want to be yelled by Gordon
right more
how does my meat taste okay the other
question I ask every guest is to tell us
your worst pants [ __ ] story oh my
god yes or close call but you can only
use three words or three small phrases
so mine for example is college jogging
front lawn yes mine is suit
squishy car flu lavender usually you
don't yeah okay let's go question
someone says what is your stripper name
or what would you name each other as
strippers I mean a fire oh love me long
time oh yeah both are very very exotic
and beautiful next to stage is Latino
fire two for whoa someone's asking which
do ya'll prefer the hey [ __ ] podcasts
are filming and all girls JK news oh hey
[ __ ] all day really yeah all day yeah
why is that dude I think like last time
we filmed we found out that one of our
girls Bo's gets really uncomfortable
when people show her our boobs or show
her your boobs
so her their boobs yeah yeah yeah that's
very funny be ourselves it's fun yeah
someone's asking worst public
transportation story does your bougie
ass take public transportation this was
in Paris actually and it was Paris for
one of our cast mates Tiffani it was her
wedding okay in the middle of July okay
and Paris gets [ __ ] hot right and we
were taking a actually we were taking
ubers everywhere mm-hmm so yeah it's
questionable thing observational very
interesting right and they don't use
air-conditioning oh yeah they just roll
down their windows everywhere and man
the Palace of Versailles back to our
city was like an hour Oh like I was
mouth breathing the whole time
one of our friends Brandon beat Roy
literally right when he got out of the
the uber Winston a bushing just puked
someone's asking what's the best and
worst part of being on social media best
part is I mean you obviously have your
fans so like they're you know like you
you touch their lives or they they give
you like the thumbs up and they really
support you so that's obviously always
like very kind the bad side of that
everyone always has an opinion on your
life yeah yeah yeah sweet messages
always gets me and I love him like I
make it a point to I don't accept their
message because then they can constantly
you know yeah but I go to their patient
just like like 16 photos so they know
that message but on the other hand yeah
they hate messages but also just the the
sheer stupidity oh you know just the
sheer [ __ ] stupidity no comments like
like it's even like small things like
hey I'll post a picture like I got this
baby from Walmart and someone will
comment where'd you get that baby and
I'm like hey baby scared it shows it the
whole time yeah in hopes that it doesn't
move because I'm gonna be
Oh No sorry if it's sentimental to you
it really is 9 okay started as the
mascot and then it has become a ever
since
yeah it's okay people have very visceral
reactions to it thank you for holding it
in for this long the entire time
well Gio here's a question someone asks
what are the pros and cons of shooting
either a JK news video versus a family
vlog the pros and cons the pro is when
I'm shooting jake kinney's video
everyone else is doing all the work and
like I'm fortunate enough that I'm
around a lot of funny people yeah that
are just fearless and say whatever they
want versus the home ones I'm doing all
the stuff home by myself so I'm just
like I don't know I'm just like blooming
yeah I feel like holding a camera while
a baby is trying to suplex you is really
nice okay and this person was a question
for each of you Gina fav ho story
ngo dumbest Bart story oh okay this is
partially my fault I kind of built an
image of being a ho over the years I
look like it you know definitely
definitely look like you grab your boobs
like three times here but throughout the
years the girls quickly realize like GT
you're kind of kind of a prude I'm kind
of conservative yeah this [ __ ] is
sucking mouths a quarter of a mile back
to you so my husband and I we're always
talking about like who has a better
memory like we're competitive is like
weak okay this is just a little glimpse
of our life um so we're teaching our son
how to play basketball but not really
just like the dribble a ball and kind of
make it in it like a little kid basket
like George yeah so then um oh no it was
baseball so he has like a little T thing
and then he like hits it right uh-huh so
then
the competitiveness turns up and then
like like we kind of like we shoe our
kid out of the picture yeah and then I
just wrote I'm like oh [ __ ] where's
Tycho but the store the stupid story
here is um he swears he has a better
memory than I do I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm gonna get you on this
so we were at REI shopping for some gear
for our friends who were going on some
like really crazy oh they were in
Iceland okay um and then I was like hey
well um Casey you Bernie just buy
whatever Bart war he had a jacket he had
a vest on pence whatever right and then
my Bart's like I've never worn a vest
never worn a best I was a terrible thing
argue my petty ass goes off to the side
I go on his Instagram and I find the
picture of him wearing a vest I'm like
yeah [ __ ] here's a back I don't
I think until the day I die I'm gonna
remember this story it's so stupid
as for a ho story I can't think of any
host stories but it's good but I think
the closest I get is I can get is when
the girls really started learning what
kind of [ __ ] I'm into oh okay I like
depraved [ __ ] I'm into like the sexual
[ __ ] yeah really full podcast on there
yeah I got messages of like concern like
are you okay she likes near-death
experiences Oh
like the thrill of that yeah yeah like
like I told the girls so many times I've
gotten choked out to the point where I
passed out and I popped a blood vessel
and I had like blood spots all over me
okay yes like I want it to be like I
want to see the light of God okay I've
heard a friend say that before so that
is a little concerning but as long as
you're having a good time
someone's asked me what's a video idea
you've had for a while or something
y'all think would make a great video but
hasn't happened yet hmm video we were to
do a porn we'd probably make great money
oh man oh you're going there
not a porn are we making it's like an
interracial I don't want to kiss you
though its generation it's fine
you don't know where this man is I
understand yes I mean is it a porn video
with us that you want to do it if we did
like all six Hebrews podcast we'd make
[ __ ] aliens
I wouldn't want to I don't know I guess
the slumber party idea that you had I
want to beat the [ __ ] out of your kid oh
okay or on Tyga's Instagram uh-huh every
time you I have what we call cute
aggression okay and where are things
when they're too cute you want to cause
pain yeah yeah I would love I was
telling the other day I would love to do
a video of me watching your kid for 24
hours Oh be stress that I go through a
very intense that would be as I'm scared
but yeah kids like six weeks all you can
probably [ __ ] me up someone's I think
what's something you want to tell you
from five years ago five years ago damn
um five years ago I would say be nice to
yourself yeah like um
be kind to yourself give yourself credit
give yourself compliments and don't
compare yourself to other people this
sounds so cliche yes but that's like
literally that's why they're cliches
yeah yeah that makes sense that's what I
would tell myself I would say calm the
hell down 25 at 25 I was just like um
kind of heavily stressed like what am I
doing with my life what's going on yeah
just rejected me am i terrible I'm never
like I think I don't have those hormones
or maybe I was just very like everything
kind of just the lights were shining
brighter on see my into my eyes I'm just
like oh my god I'm so freaked out
stressed out and everything was like the
end of the world yeah yeah yeah and then
now that I'm 30 I'm just like and also
you weren't as fat as you thought you
were
fantastic baby good thing about from 30
yeah we're still advice on how to work
with strong women um respect them and
and don't view yourself as less than
yeah because we all have our strengths
and we all have our weaknesses like we
have our geniuses and you have our
idiots within ourselves you know like
that whole positive/negative yin and
yang thing um so areas where she's
strong I might be completely weak but I
don't consider myself a weak person yeah
and and just like respecting that yeah
yeah never seeing each other is
competition yeah like Geo she's very
alpha very strong and like she said
she's she does things that blows my mind
I'm like I never knew that yeah thank
you like being responsible that's one
day a lot of people do that I never saw
his competition I've actually always
looked up to her you know I mean yeah
everything she did I'm like man I'm
gonna do that one day so it's I never it
was just never a competition to me it
was more like this is big sister who I
want to be hmm and like she probably
sees that in other girls too she's like
oh I see that in you yeah yeah it's that
like in the beginning of our porn girls
listen to I'm sure the next a [ __ ]
podcasts to hear how the rest of the
porn goes yeah before you guys go though
every guest that's on the podcast that
makes time gets a personalized fortune
cookie you guys reached out to my
culture for you guys with your fortune
saying okay oh oh yeah they're headin
yeah yeah yeah you guys did a good job
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
we are very sad to report that on
multiple occasions when people were
describing you to others they said you
were Corki or so
because only ditional yeah my immediacy
ation with that word you know I've come
to realize that I really dislike people
who describe themselves as quirky well
I'm keeping this this was just for you
all right this is cute okay this one
says banging your head on the wall for
one hour straight burns 150 calories
this is fact you guys this is not a
fortune this is fact but we [ __ ] there's
multiple people writing this fortune but
we advise you not to do that and just go
to your gym instead oh how did they know
no we got lucky yeah no where can people
find everything that you guys are up to
everything that just kidding is doing
the podcast all of that oh [ __ ] or do
they just go to geo underscore
Antoinette mm-hmm and and then just go
to my Instagram miss Jeana darling
that's Mis and they'll find all the
[ __ ] yeah miss Jeana just darling
yeah yeah listen to the hey [ __ ]
podcast ever you listen to your podcast
and thank you guys so much thank you
we'll see you guys next time on an
episode of not too deep good bye
2deep 2deep 2deep 2deep whatever
struggles you are facing from depression
and anxiety to trauma and grief better
help can connect you with the
professional counselor in a safe and
private online environment it's
convenient you can schedule secure video
or phone sessions as well as chat and
text with your therapists and anything
you share is completely confidential
best of all it is a truly affordable
option and you'll get 10% off your first
month with the discount code grace so
why not get started go to better help
comm such grace and fill out a
questionnaire to get matched with a
counselor that you'll love today not too
deep is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa Dumont's
writing by Diane Kang a production
assistants by Katrina Henning
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]